okay it is truly an honor to be here I
would like to thank the Academy for
recognizing this film amongst the work
of such a talented diverse and inspiring
group of filmmakers at the beginning of
last year I wasn't really sure of what I
was doing or where I was going with my
senior film all I had was the word
re-gifted and a desire to make something
special I owe it to my teacher
Paul Downs for helping me develop this
story and Shawn McLaughlin for helping
me realize it a lot of blood sweat and
tears went into this film but I will
never forget the first time I sat with
an audience and saw it on the big screen
it was the most amazing feel feeling and
will remain a constant reminder of why
we puts why we put so much of ourselves
into this medium I would like to thank
my peers at Ringling for always having
my back a huge thanks to my composer and
sound designer Valentin LeFort lastly I
would like to dedicate this award to my
eye and other special thanks to my
parents and the rest of the shocked
Lockland
for their constant love and support
thank you
[Applause]